you know it's funny in the comments
section in my rate review I've got a lot
of requests for hard-boiled I should see
hard-boiled I've actually seen
hard-boiled SOT in the late 90s it was
great but I'd want to watch it again if
I were to do a video on it and I don't
own hard-boiled it got me on a John Woo
kick though and well Broken Arrow I have
that watched a couple days ago since I'm
on this 90s action movie kick you know
what this is Friday's video
[Music]
so broken arrows directed by John Woo
stars John Travolta and Christian Slater
they're flying a stealth bomber with a
couple of nukes in the back and Travolta
like I'm gonna steal these nukes because
the year is 1995 and that's what we do
in movies so he does that Christian
Slater lives through the experience and
now Christian Slater is the only man who
can stop him and a park ranger played by
Samantha Mathis which if there was a
positive in the Super Mario Brothers
movie she is it but what's the decade
that's right the 90s I've said it a
couple times before and I'm gonna say it
again it's the villain it's John
Travolta man he's the one carrying this
whole thing John Travolta had a comeback
after Pulp Fiction it's like Pulp
Fiction
wow that guy is he's good let's put him
in more stuff oh wow he's great as a
villain and it's John Travolta just
having so much fun in this role you're
out of your mind ain't it cool to the
point yeah it's not just because it was
Vincent Vega and also will scarlet
there's been one's gonna cast a bigger
shadow
John Travolta he's the uncontested
champion of this movie he carries the
entire thing maybe it's because really
for the most part Travolta doesn't have
any other villain goons around him that
really challenge him warden from
Shawshank was great in the movie as that
guy you know exactly who he's gonna play
you know the guy's not the military guy
maybe he was a financial backer he's
someone they needed to get the job done
now he's just prattling on and bitching
about everything and you know Travolta
is just gonna smash his windpipe with a
flashlight that's how it's gonna go down
you know now I'm thinking about I feel
like that's cutting him short I feel
like Travolta could have been on screen
with anybody he still would have stood
out he was great I have no complaint to
the fact this movie's the Travolta show
will this being a John Woo movie John
was known for his you know as John Woo
action shooting stuff Sir John Woo ish
things you expect in a John Woo movie
and that's not really what Broken Arrow
is not that it's devoid of shootouts it
does have those but the action in broken
Arrow's never what stood out to me not
only are there better action movies out
there there are better John Woo action
movies out there at least when comparing
the action scenes to me it's it's
Travolta which he should put that on a
t-shirt he should have a t-shirt that
says I upstaged John woos action scenes
in a John Woo movie which means Travolta
is a double edged sword he steals the
movie but also when he's not on screen
I'm not that engaged you just always
waiting for him to come back on screen
not that I don't like Christian Slater I
mean I voice Christian Slater's one of
those actors have always been like now
it's your time hey raise your hand if
you watched the entire series all nine
episodes of my own worst enemy when it
was airing yeah
Broken Arrow is one of those movies for
me it doesn't have that hero and villain
going toe-to-toe for screen time it is a
TKO with a favor of John Travolta when
he's not on screen I'm always just
waiting for him to come back actually
you know what there are a couple things
that do stand out and Newt getting
detonated underground which really isn't
an action scene it's just it's a nuke
scene followed by one of the greatest
line deliveries in cinematic history
good luck following up that line how we
long though in the 90s how we long was
my pick for Eddie Brock just because he
looked like I'm simply on that basis I
think we got a better one now funny
enough Woody Harrelson was also my pick
for cletus kasady because the Natural
Born Killers so that weirdly worked out
and the scene that made me laugh my ass
off even when I saw the movie in
theatres which is when Travolta gets
nailed by the nuke and by Travolta I
meet the dummy that's clearly the dummy
that's just turns out maybes because
he's making a different face to vultures
like bring it on
dummies like Oh funny enough movies like
this are known for the infamous will
they won't they thing you know you got
the hero and you got the hot chick our
hero and hot chick gonna hook up not
really no I mean there's this hand
embrace at the end which is probably
gonna lead to a date but not only they
get down in the mine or anything the
Christian Slater does know when to put
on the moves though it's like oh you're
freezing let me warm you I appreciated
the fact that it was like wool for
concentrating on all that that we're not
concentrating on the situation at hand
and the props in the movie for that the
musical score that Hans Zimmer's score
Bom Bom Bom a score so good that Houston
screamed whoo for Dewey
yeah there's this cowboy quality to John
Travolta totally fits I'm also Dewey
definitely shows the diversity in music
and the application of movie and how it
all works together music can change a
scene or a scene can change the music in
the end Broken Arrow it's another
product of the 90s for voltages so much
fun in this role it's like every line
every response I don't know how much of
it is ad-libs what is it just sticks
with you and that's the mark of a good
characters when you walk away from the
movie and you remember those lines and
use them in application in the world my
friends and I if there's ever a long
pause we still go we do it that's an
interaction we actually do to this day
feel like the thing I appreciate is
Broken Arrow is very self-aware travolta
knew how to play the villain up the
movie knows what it is this one of those
movies I can pop in and have it in the
background and have it on and watch it
understand the travolta shows a good
time no alcohol required I feel like I'm
more generous with these nineties action
movies because in nostalgia of it is the
nature at the base
alright so Broken Arrow have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]